this video is sponsored by bok su no
other character represents the moral
landscape of the one piece world
as well as monkey d garp the hero
of the marines as the father of the most
wanted person in the world as well as
the grandfather of the future pirate
king and the son of the old one
garp without any doubt plays a quite
unique role in the story
especially given the fact that he's one
of the most respected members within the
marines
the sworn enemy of pirates and
revolutionaries alike
[Music]
and yet the two defining traits of his
character max to his kind-hearted and
goofy nature
are his strong sense of duty as well as
his love for his criminal family
and as we will see it is exactly this
stark polarization of beliefs that makes
him such a tragic
and lovable person this is the story of
monkey d
garden
[Music]
garb is mostly known for two feats the
defeat of the rox pirates on god valley
as well as the capture of gold d roger
even though garp has enjoyed immense
respect and special treatment within the
marines for them
both of these events have actually been
doctored as we now know
roger actually handed himself in
willingly to trigger the next pirate era
meanwhile he actually fought side by
side with garb to defeat rox
which makes it very hard to assess how
strong
he truly is
since he was able to fight with some of
the most powerful beings in the one
piece world however
and was offered the position of admiral
multiple times
it's pretty safe to assume that garb is
very much the real deal
from a storytelling perspective garb
actually has a quite unique character
design
or to put it in better terms he doesn't
seem to fit in
any traditional trope or category even
though he's the grandfather to both
luffy and ace and was the one who
trained them both
he doesn't really fit the trope of the
classical old man mentor
that role falls to rayleigh for luffy
and to whitebeard for ace
a better fit might be that of a parental
figure that he
clearly is to both of the boys however
while he showered both of them with
tough love
he also didn't exactly stick around all
too much as well
in the end i believe that garp is
several important supporting characters
mashed into one for example he
represents the old era from the marines
perspective
that includes other legends like roger
or whitebeard
he is a father figure to the main
character balanced in such a way that
luffy has experienced both
love and care in his childhoods while
still benefiting from the classical
shonen hero without parents trope that
gives him independence and drive
kind of ironic actually that luffy
mostly grew up an orphan
even though he has both an actual father
and grandfather who are both still alive
and well
the biggest role that garth plays in the
story however is that he represents the
blurred moral lines between the
different groups
operating in the one piece worlds like
no other as we all know the notion that
all marines are good
and all pirates are evil is pretty much
thrown out the window within the first
few chapters
instead we learn that there are good
marines and bad marines just as there
are good pirates and bad pirates
and of course a ton of people who fall
somewhere in between
for example we know that the marines who
claim to be fighting for peace and
justice
also serve at the will of the celestial
dragons a tyrannical regime of hedonic
slave owners
at the same time while a lot of pirates
simply seek freedom from this regime of
oppression
many are just as terrible on the other
end of the table
killing and terrorizing the innocent
civilians who are
helplessly caught between both fronts
and so monkey d-garp is the
personification of the question
what does it mean to be good this is
actually a quite
interesting theme within the monkey
family while luffy literally values
family above all
else as we see with his crew or with ace
and
rejects any sense of duty to any system
his father dragon on the other hand
ended up putting duty above all else
even if it meant
abandoning his own child garp meanwhile
is
literally torn between both duty and
family
looking for a way to balance them not
always successfully
in the end what all three of them desire
is freedom and a just world
free of the terror of the celestial
dragons but also from
pirates like blackbeard or doflamingo
however based on each of their ideals
luffy chose the path of piracy
dragon that of the revolutionary and
garb that of the marine
and while luffy represents the best
within the world of pirates
garp very clearly embodies the best
within the marines
his approach to justice i've actually
talked about that of the four marine
admirals as well
is by far the most human and relatable
making him the flagship of that type of
marine
that we as an audience want to see and
that in the future will likely end up
becoming the new normal this includes
people like smoker or aokiji who see him
as a role model
but also a line of young marines like
kobe
who garb chose and trained himself
i would actually argue then that garb as
a member of the d-clan and the notorious
monkey family
is the one who is quietly nursing a more
just and independent generation of
marines
with the freedom and desire to actually
work for and protect the people
and not the celestial dragons before we
move on to the tragic part of garp's
character however let's
first lighten the mood a bit as you may
or may not know
it's finally the long-awaited sakura
season here in japan
and to celebrate the occasion the kind
folks over at box zoo sent me
this wonderful snack box boxu is a
monthly snack box subscription service
that delivers original assortments of
premium japanese snacks and tea pairings
directly from japan to wherever you live
and as i get it there is a different
theme for every season
and since i love hanami i got lucky and
got the sakura one so
let's open this bad boy up and see
what's inside because i absolutely love
the snacks here in japan
i love the bubble wrap
how cute is that i actually love this so
it does
come with a description of all the
contents
of the box itself this here is the green
tea what i really like about this
is that they collaborate with
traditional japanese family
manufacturers that make these snacks and
candies
so you don't just get some random stuff
you can also get in any japanese
supermarket
but actual local stuff i think
especially when you're outside of japan
this
is a great opportunity to try some real
authentic japanese food
try this monaco because it actually
looks really good
looks like uh this
[Music]
this is sakura cake if you would like to
try it out for yourself you can get 10
of your own boxes snack box and save up
to 47 bucks using my
code and links in description below
and this brings us back to the tragedy
of garp's character his inner divide
between
love towards his family and duty towards
the organization that he believes will
bring justice to the world
we can see this divide very clearly in
the fact that garp has a very
interesting approach to dealing with
pirates which is
judging them based on their actions and
their personality as
he is well aware of the dark system
overshadowing the marines as well we
know this because garb
doesn't actually make a secret out of
his disdain for the world nobles
in fact the only reason he never
accepted any promotion above vice
admiral
was because the positions of fleet
admiral and admiral are under the direct
command of the world governments
as a result similar to smoker and luffy
he started to build an actual
relationship with roger after chasing
him for so many years
in the end their relationship was of
such mutual respect and understanding
that they not only fought together
roger actually entrusted garb with his
precious child
telling him that he trusted him as much
as his crew which
let's be honest is a real goosebump
moment
whether he also told garb about his
plans and the knowledge he found on love
tale
remains to be seen but garb was willing
to accept his old rival's request and
took ace in
anyway garp in turn entrusts ace to
dardan and then some time later luffy as
well
occasionally paying them visits and
hoping to shape them into future marines
each of them has their own reason to
become a pirate and disobey him but
this doesn't change the fact that they
are family and so he continues to pour
his love onto them albeit through fists
of love
and garb wanting ace and luffy to become
marines shows us just how much he
actually respects his job
no doubt hoping to make his voice part
of this new generation
and yet despite these expectations he
keeps laughing whenever he hears about
luffy's exploits in the worlds
even when the marines are directly
involved and so it's no real surprise
that marine fort was not only the climax
for luffy's character arc so far
but of garbs as well when he sits next
to his grandson who is about to be
executed
there was not a hint of a smile
garp instead cries cries not only in
sorrow of seeing his grandson in such a
situation
but also cries because of his inability
to do anything about it
his life as a marine has tied his hands
completely
in the end garp decides to choose duty
over family
as he takes down marco who had no issues
dealing with the other admirals so far
he boosts the morale of the marines and
then just
moments later he has to witness luffy
his second grandson
running towards him the ultimate dilemma
now he was standing in the way of one
grandson rescuing his other grandson
and so in this moment of turmoil as he
sees his happy days with the boys pass
before his eyes
he gives himself up and allows luffy to
punch him and pass
[Music]
and so i believe that the true reason
garp is so incredibly enraged at a kainu
killing ace is that right from the start
he never
actually thought that ace was going to
be executed
instead he fully expected that
whitebeard and his crew and later luffy
would save ace as a result we got one of
the most emotional and heartbreaking
scenes in the story as sengoku has to
restrain himself from murdering akainu
and the same goes for his reaction to
shanks arriving who was responsible for
setting luffy
on the same path as ace and so on this
day
garb the marine won but garb the man
lost now i personally would like to
believe that garb will have the chance
to choose again at some point in the
future
to save his other grandson or stay loyal
to the marines
and this time he will choose family over
duty if you want to watch more of my
character analyses you can simply click
up here or if you want to see my latest
video down
there thanks for watching peace